so last week or the week before I
brought you my favorite tick talker of
the week yeah which
is popping off man he's been popping off
actually like yeah he had like 50 000
followers at that time now he's got a
hundred I think he's doubled he's going
up since that time it's going up but
since then people have been sending me
content that sort of has the same Vibe
similar Vibe yeah I hate to use the term
NPC but it's just like I I would say
this is more just normal normal people
videos right and people not trying to do
anything for the camera it's just their
normal life which is cool because I feel
that we
you know
I think no one will admit it but the
beginning of tick tock everyone liked it
because there's all these people who
were like
you know
a little bit maybe a little bit off yeah
okay you know it may be a little bit
unwell okay just uploading that is true
yeah and everyone's like yeah yeah right
and you know they like to pretend that
the app was you know
yeah yeah yeah everyone's on there like
yo look at this mentally ill person yeah
yeah or like look at this like meth
addict yeah yeah and but I think
everyone was so drawn to it because we
don't have
you know people on there like our boy
who are just making things to make them
yeah because they believe in it and and
I also think
in this age of like
you know I think like Mr Beast has like
spawned this entire generation of people
that are like okay we have to like
take this random thing and drive it
across the country and somehow find this
person you know what I'm saying
in in the in the era of that this is
kind of a breath of fresh air like or or
we can just go to Walmart and [__] do
nothing do nothing so I bring you my
favorite video of the week
that's fine if I come to the store and
this
soft Japanese barbecue sauce you got the
hot and spicy
the original oh boy working a little
turtle shell back there
you make sure you see that
have you guys had that before if so
now did he say whenever I come into this
store I think so I think this is just a
Walmart I think
no I like that I like this store
why it's kind of a subtle
it's a good
we're here at Walmart yeah it's a store
yeah yeah okay I like that yeah it's
like a little bit of a flex like calm
down yeah yeah it's just it's just a
store when I come to this store yeah
yeah this catches my eye it's like it's
Walmart for you because it's a special
occasion when you go here for me this is
just like it's a store yeah
one of the many
frequent yeah
you pause it the perfect time because
that's the end of the video Perfect have
you have any of you guys tried it let me
know
and that's the end he doesn't get it he
just says one of these times one of
these times I might buy it it's the
perfect video it's like how everyone
walks through a store it's like I've
been meaning to buy that but I don't
really want to carry it today so I'm not
gonna get it yeah
you know well this is also this has the
same Vibe as you know a father gets a
camera and they're filming their 14 year
old son yeah okay we're live
let me just say something random yeah
are we going to this uh like the this
sauce I might get it one time okay you
love that sauce don't you wave by one of
these times I'm gonna buy that for you
yeah okay okay just try it my guy what
do you want us to say
ah
just try it bro
he wants to know if any of you guys have
tried it though so Brian that's what
you're supposed to say he wants have you
tried it that's awesome I have not tried
okay yeah I haven't tried the sauce
either you seem like a nice guy but man
what is going on
everyone bugging out by someone just
normal
they're so ain't they just don't get it
that's what I'm saying you know what it
is he's just treating it like a like ask
Reddit
yeah yeah which
is so jarring to people yeah when you
use a video to just pose a question yeah
that's gonna be my new YouTube angle
just a million questions
I'm just gonna start a channel called a
million questions and everything short
every day yeah hey guys have you tried
Evian water got a cue for you what's the
best bottled water yeah
I'll tell you mine but I actually want
to know what your guys's favorite is
yeah that would probably go crazy on the
algorithm yeah for sure 20 000 replies
every day yeah quick cue
um
what do you guys like on your hot dogs
yeah see ya what's the best slot machine
yeah and why is it rich little piggies
yeah
okay look at him see now he's [__] he
gets a little Fame and now he wants to
tell us how to think piece of [__] this
guy is a classic Myspace presentation
yeah helmet hair yeah you know
looks like he's in a pop punk band yep
that's my favorite video of the week now
I wouldn't say he's my favorite tick
talker of the week because I went on his
page and he doesn't you know
that video had had some traction so I'm
comfortable bringing it up right you
know the rest of his stuff is kind of
yeah random you know that's kind of cool
like he's only got 5 000 followers
not that that doesn't matter but I
didn't want to like pull this guy up and
be like
not that we're clowning him but you get
it we're not saying yeah we're not we're
not
he's uh you know he's out here hustling
yeah posing questions to the world yep
trying to connect trying to network and
there was one other thing I wanted to
show you let this be a lesson guys girls
wherever you are just be yourself
yeah
be yourself don't try too hard that's
the most endearing thing you're sitting
there thinking yeah yeah yeah uh don't
try too hard yeah exactly don't try too
hard
just be yourself just be yourself you
don't need props no I do want to show
you this one more video okay thank you
another favorite video of the week you
know yeah I had contribute I have two
favorite videos of the week I feel like
I need to contribute
yeah
God damn why listen you listening
oh my gosh
tornadoes
[Music]
if we tell you that you need a shelter
you need to go to the back of this
hallway where he's pointing go through
the double door security will take you
to the very back of the warehouse where
there are no windows
and that's where you will be I'll show
you tornado
stop being an idiot serious
[Music]
he said okay I'll leave You're Gonna
Leave
bro that's like that's like walking up
naked in Second Life into someone's
house so you tornado yeah exactly
out of here y'all
that was sick though I was [__] sick
right so you tornado
and he's about to go in bro they cut him
off that was whack
who stopped him
oh they knocked it out his hand grabbed
that [__] bro stop this is serious she
knew her husband liked it she was like
don't do this in front of him yeah yeah
exactly where I was about to get all
into it he's like hell yeah
she's like no David stop it I'm leaving
You're Gonna Leave You're Gonna Leave
damn that dialogue man her face I like
that that security guard's got to dip
into yeah
is this a bar
it has to be right man with how long it
takes it's crazy they weren't just like
get out of here
with how long it took that lady to
explain they would have died yeah I know
it's just crazy that they like like that
everyone's still like standing there
partying yeah they're like the party can
keep going just if we tell you to
shelter you gotta do it